aria-labelledby is an example of what we
refer to as a relationship attribute.
A relationship attribute creates
some kind of semantic relationship
between elements on the page.
In the case of aria-labelledby,
that relationship is this element
is labeled by that element, or
as the case may be, this element
is labeled by those elements.
The Aria 1.0 spec lists several
relationship attributes,
with a few more coming in at Aria 1.1.
Most Aria relationship attributes
take a reference to one or
more elements to create a new link
between elements on the page.
What differs in each case
is what that link means and
how it is presented to users.
One of the most widely used Aria
relationships is aria-owns.
This allows us to tell assistive
technology that an element, which is
separate in the DOM, should be treated
as a child of the current element,
or to rearrange existing child
elements into a different order.
For example, if a pop-up submenu is
visually positioned near its parent
menu, but cannot be a DOM child of it
because that would affect the visual
presentation, or because the element
is used in several different contexts,
we can use aria-owns to present the
submenu as a child of the parent menu.
In terms of the accessibility tree,
we start off with two menus which
aren't semantically linked in any way.
If the submenu is showing, an assistive
technology user would not be able
to explore into it in
the context of the other menu.
It would appear after the end of it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
By setting aria-owns on a placeholder
in the top level menu, we can express
the submenu relationship without
affecting the appearance of the submenu.
aria-owns can take a list
of ID references, so
it can also be used to explicitly
specify the order of children.
For example, to rearrange children, or
into live native and
non-native children.
By default, aria-owned children will
come after natively-owned children.
aria-activedescendant plays
a related role.
Just as the active element of
a page is the one which has focus,
setting the active descendant of
an element allows us to tell assistive
technology that when its
parent has page focus,
it should be presented to the user
as the actual focused element.
For example, if we have a list box
widget, we may wish to keep focus
on the list box container, so that it
can receive keyboard events and keep its
aria-activedescendant attribute updated
to the currently selected list item.
This makes the currently selected
item appear to assistive technology
as if it is the focused item.
aria-describedby allows you to provide
an accessible description, in the exact
same way that aria-labelledby
allows you to provide a label.
This is a useful technique whenever
there is some extra explanatory text
that a user might need,
whether that applies to only users of
assistive technology or all users.
One common example is a password input
field, which is accompanied by some
descriptive text explaining
the requirements for a valid password.
Unlike a label, the description may or
may not ever be presented to the user.
They may have a choice of whether
to access it or it may come after
all the other information and
be preempted by something else.
For example, if they start entering
information, their input would be
echoed back and interact with
the description of the element.
So description is a great way
to communicate information,
which is supplementary,
but not essential.
It won't get in the way of other
more essential information,
like the role of the element.
Like aria-labelledby,
aria-describedby may reference elements
which are otherwise not visible,
whether they're hidden from the DOM or
hidden from assistive technology users.
The remaining two relationship
attributes are a little different and
work together.
aria-posinset, short for position inset,
and aria-setsize are about
defining a relationship between sibling
elements in a set, such as a list.
In the case where the size of the full
set cannot be determined by the elements
present in the DOM, such as when lazy
rendering is used to avoid having all of
our large lists in the DOM
at any given time,
aria-setsize can be used to specify
the actual size of the set.
And aria-posinset can be used to specify
the position of the element in the set.
For example, in a set which might
potentially contain 1,000 elements,
I can say that a particular element
has an aria-posinset of 857,
even though it appears first in the DOM.
And then use dynamic HTML techniques
to ensure the user can explore the full
list on demand.
Note that aria-setsize is set
on the items in the set and
not on the set container.